good morning hank it's tuesday so i've
been writing stories fairly consistently
since i was about eight years old so
this is a bit of a funny thing to say
but over the last six weeks i
re-realized that i really enjoy writing
like during my semi-secret sabbatical i
got a fair amount of writing done and i
loved it in a way i'd kind of forgotten
about so back in 2003 when i was working
on the story that would eventually
become looking for alaska and sarah and
i were first becoming friends she
introduced me to the old line that all
writing is rewriting and this is true in
at least two ways right like first off
for me anyway most of what is good about
a story emerges in revision like i don't
think i've ever written a paragraph that
didn't need extensive revision let alone
a novel like in 2003 i was writing a
novel i guess but i wasn't writing
looking for alaska because i deleted
like 95
of the draft that i wrote in 2003 along
the way to writing looking for alaska
but all writing is rewriting is also
true in a more literal way because even
the initial act of writing something
down is a kind of rewriting you are
taking ideas that exist inside of your
mind and trying to find language for
them and that act of translating ideas
into words is like revision in its most
basic sense it is a revisioning of
thought into language i really enjoy
that process and when it's working i can
enter a kind of flow state where i feel
absolutely engrossed which is a terrible
word for a beautiful feeling sometimes i
just think that we want what we don't
have and what i don't have is calm and
writing makes me feel calm in the way
like puzzling or crafting might and yes
of course there are many moments of
frustration why did i paint myself into
this corner why can't i solve this plot
problem once again i find myself up
against the limits of my own talents and
etc but for me the engrossed calm more
than makes up for those times of
frustration but that's the thing i sort
of knew about myself before returning to
fiction writing the thing i had
forgotten is how much i enjoy writing
stories even when i'm not writing them
because when i'm working on a story i
have something to think about like when
i'm going to bed and my thoughts are
racing i am less likely to get stuck on
obsessive fears because i can think
about what might happen in the story
when i'm driving alone i can listen to
podcasts but i don't need to listen to
podcasts because i don't need to be
distracted from my thoughts instead i
often find that i want to be alone with
my thoughts that i want to let my mind
drift around and see what it can find
because i'm thinking about the story now
to be clear the vast majority of
thoughts i have while letting my mind
wander are terrible like i think of plot
solutions that seem brilliant in the
moment but are absolutely ridiculous and
sometimes i even write these ideas down
with like no awareness that they're
ridiculous as in the first draft of the
fault in our stars where a girl and her
favorite author team up to
take down a drug lord i wrote that i
wrote that scene and at no point in
writing it that i think
this is stupid so it's not like these
are high quality thoughts but they are
nonetheless fun thoughts to have and so
one of the gifts writing stories gives
me one that i don't get as much from
writing nonfiction is the joy of pure
imagination what in my childhood was
known as make believe i love that phrase
so much by the way it feels like an
order make believe so what else happened
over the last six weeks a lot of family
stuff a lot of work i rehabbed my foot
which is now wearing a normal shoe
instead of a boot even if it isn't
totally recovered oh also i got to spend
some glorious minutes filling out the
semi-annual nerdfighteria census hank
this was an unusually wonderful census
and not only because you included
questions such as how do we solve a
problem like wag luigi it's hard to
overstate the importance of the census
because it helps us to understand the
values and priorities of the community
so that hopefully we can reflect those
back in our work and over the years it
has had a huge impact on everything from
crash course to our work with partners
in health so if you've already filled
out the census thank you if you haven't
there's a link in the doobly-doo hank
i'll see you on friday